[Music]
team usa women's hockey is one step
closer to defending the gold medal they
won four years ago after their 4-1 win
over the czech republic overnight jamie
yuka spoke to members of the team before
they arrived in beijing and joins us
again from the olympic village there
jamie i hear the team is on a mission
for more than just medals
absolutely you can say that again
michelle this team is not only talented
but has some engaging characters focus
on the task at hand they have big dreams
not just for themselves like you're
saying but for the game they love
shooting for back to back golds the
american women also have an even bigger
goal we're the hope right we're the
women that are doing it like we're in
the trenches building something building
a future not just for themselves but
their sport
i grew up in a place where a woman
didn't really play hockey at all so i
was a figure skater
to start out i hated it so much
without leagues of their own when abby
rock and her teammates were kids many
just laced up with the boys
growing up playing with the guys was for
sure hard on parents to watch me maybe
get buried in the boards like i'd get
hit and i just pop pray back up here in
beijing team usa is looking to bounce
back from an opening round loss to their
top rival for the gold canada we hate
one another right i love that you just
put it out there we hate them yeah i
mean i would describe it as like within
the rules slaughtering them right like
that's what as a competitor i want them
to do that to us
rock's dad is canadian and she's a dual
citizen but made it clear to her father
from an early age which team she was on
he had to switch his hats and put on the
usa cab i feel kind of bad for dad
he's switched sides to the good side but
rock still skates with her dad's
heritage as the first indigenous woman
to wear officially the team usa hockey
jersey the tribes are in an area where
hockey is a big deal but you're the
first to be going to the olympics yeah i
played with so many indigenous hockey
players
obviously they're all guys do you think
there are more little girls putting on
ice skates up in these areas because of
you i sure hope so
and for many on her team that is the
ultimate goal
do you look at usa hockey as a little
bit like where soccer was 20 years ago
yeah what soccer had in 99 is what we
have now and that's how far behind we
are but establishing a successful
women's pro league remains a challenge
knight has been working on it for years
and pledges to continue the fight we
haven't had the appropriate time to
develop the sport and people want it
right now
and that takes investment teammate
brianna decker whose olympics ending
injury dealt a serious setback to team
usa already is focused on the next
generation with a foundation to fund
girls hockey programs you put your money
where your mouth is in terms of getting
younger women into the sport it's
incredible to see that i can make a
direct impact on young kids
decker and knight are mentors to
teammates like caroline harvey an
exceptionally talented defender who's
not even in college yet for me to be a
mentor to her she's already better than
me and she's you know 10 11 years
younger than i am is there a
generational divide when it comes to
what music gets played i know joel rule
comes on and they're like don't even
know who that is or tupac comes on and
they have no idea who tupac is not a lot
of tick tock going on with the 30 year
olds on the team so it's but that's
that's what makes it fun is that fun for
you yeah i like trying to incorporate
the older girls the older girls can we
call them veterans yeah thanks
thank
you now with the injured veteran out
first time olympian abby rock is
stepping up to take her spot and help
defend the gold i think a successful
olympics really is a gold medal
that is the goal is to come out on top
we need to bring back hope to the us and
we're the ones that can do it
[Applause]
these women are clearly having fun but
make no mistake about it expectations
here are high the u.s women's hockey
team has never left the olympics without
a medal they take on the winner of
finland and japan coming up tony
i like their chances go team usa jamie
yukas thank you very much we appreciate
it uh i love
what that one young lady said about uh
they want to slaughter them within the
rules slaughter them yeah well hockey is
hardcore but it's like the point made
about it being where soccer was
20 years ago you you invest in these
sports with women at the helm
and they just climb they explode i i am
a little bit disheartened to hear that
ja rule is now the old person artist
that hurt a little bit who would have
ever thought